les contrôles de transport routier
s'enchaînent au péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines c'est le
résultat d'une grande opération de
contrôles organisés mardi 6 juillet par
les directions régionales de
l'environnement de l'aménagement et des
transports d'île de france et du centre
val de loire
l'enjeu de cette journée c'est d'abord
de montrer de donner à voir
par cette mobilisation très forte une
réalité du quotidien du contrôle que
nous réalisons chaque jour en bord de
route sur les aires de service sur les
quais de chargement pour assurer le
respect de la réglementation du
transport routier et la sécurité des
usagers de la route les contrôleurs
vérifient leurs